Pues una vez ha finalizado el parón de selecciones de octubre creo que es el momento perfecto
de que actualicemos nuestro power ranking de selecciones de cara al mundial. Ya sabéis
este ranking que hacemos para establecer el top diez de favoritos de cara al próximo
mundial. El último que hagamos pues será la semana previa al que arranque la competición.
Eso hace que no haya mucho movimiento, ¿no? Los diez favoritos puede oscilar uno arriba,
uno abajo, puede entrar una selección nueva que de hecho lo hace en este power ranking.
Pero vamos, es algo que hacemos para evaluar un poquito cómo están las grandes selecciones
e ir también nosotros posicionándonos en cuanto a los candidatos, los favoritos y los
outsiders. Bueno, yo puse el ranking, lo he estado hablando con vosotros, en WhatsApp
no hubo ninguna queja. Sí, hubo alguna queja. Sí, bueno, modificaciones que hemos tenido.
Pero este ranking… ¡Va Misa! Bueno, a ver, a ver. No, no, no. A ver, que exista este ranking
es una bacalá. Perdón. Pero bueno, ¿por qué? O sea, quiero decir… ¿por qué? Yo no…
Primera… No, no, no. Voy a contextualizar. En este ranking no está Uruguay. No, no,
no. Da igual, da igual. No, no, no. No está Uruguay. Bueno, Uruguay que ha ganado sus
dos partidos del parón. Bueno, no está Uruguay. No está Uruguay. O sea, quiero decir, no
tiene… Uruguay que ha ido con reservas. O sea, a mí me dijo un analista en el pasado
Power Ranking que es la selección, creo que favorita número 40 de cara al mundial.
Entonces, yo le he hecho caso. No, no, no. Sí, sí. Me da igual que esté Uruguay o
no. O sea, quiero decir, eh… Yo lo que digo es, mola que nos juntemos aquí, hablemos
de varias selecciones con candidatas, pero oye, el ranking como tal, oye, pues tiene
la validez que tiene. O sea… Hombre, pero como todos los rankings…
Es el de Rizar Rita. … como el balón de oro que… Bueno, es que
luego la gente se hace cruces viendo el… Como cruces.
Pero así se entretienen. Mientras se hacen cruces con un ranking, no hacen otras cosas
Si nosotros estamos haciendo una labor social… Claro, claro. Es un mal menor. Entiéndelo
como un mal menor, Nau. Bueno… Pero espero que la décima hayas entendido
nuestra manera de entender. Ah, se le pasa a Daynoa. No os lo he pasado
a vosotros. Sí, sí, sí. Vale, vale.
Sí, sí. Está como me habéis dicho que esté. Porque te voy a dar un dato con la novena.
Vale. Espérate, espérate. Bueno, el caso es que se cae Uruguay del top 10 y entra en
décima posición… ¿Quién entra?
Entra en décima posición… ¿Quién entra?
La selección Colombia. Oh, ¿eh?
Cafetera. Victoria 0-4 ante México, 0-0 ante Canadá.
Muchas… Ah, que Colombia no ha ganado los dos partidos.
Ah, que Colombia no ha ganado. O sea, es que no se ha convencido mucho.
No, no, no, no. Increíble, increíble. Un dato importante que creo que infravaloramos
en el ranking en septiembre. Eliminó Uruguay en la pasada Copa América.
Claro. Eso pesa.
Eso pesa… Claro, es con carácter retroactivo.
Claro, que estaba en la reacción de Nauve. Sí, sí. Os pegaron un rejón por no meter
a Colombia y habéis querido ser políticamente correctos.
Estamos de acuerdo. Colombia tiene buena pinta.
Daniel Muñoz es muy guantilateral. Sí, sí, sí.
No jugó contra Canadá. Por eso se me agrada, claro.
Canadá muy buena selección también. Hombre…
Cristiano Río, el treinador, el excentador de League United…
¿Qué dato tenías? Sí, la canadíña.
No, es de la novena. Ah, es de la novena.
Es de la novena. Pero decimos que la novena y décima selección
en este top va a ir oscilando también. De hecho, tú proponías…
Yo iba a decir proponías. Proponías.
Proponías. Proponías.
A Noruega, que poco… Hombre, para mí Noruega viene a hacer
un parón prácticamente perfecto. No, no, no. Sí, impecable.
Pero meterla en el top 10 de favoritas al Mundial…
Sí, bueno, mejor perder una selección que solo ha ganado uno de los dos partidos que ha disputado en el parón.
¿No? Sí, lo proponiste tú.
¿Lo de Colombia? Sí.
Yo proponía a Noruega. Yo proponía a Noruega.
Vale. Vamos a meter a Noruega que no ha jugado a un Mundial desde el 98.
Claro. Y que, de hecho, no está clasificada todavía.
Bueno, pero está. Colombia sí que está.
Está semi clasificada. Pero Colombia sí que está.
Sí, ¿no? Sí, sí.
¿Está bien el dato? Sí, pero…
¿Tercera Colombia? No, pero Miguel…
¿Tercera Colombia? Miguel.
Y claro, entonces… Miguel…
Primera fue Argentina. Segunda Uruguay.
No. ¿Cómo?
Segunda Ecuador. Segunda Ecuador, claro.
Es que tenía un Jermet y Ecuador.
El problema de Ecuador es que está pasando por debajo del radar porque no tiene gol.
O sea, es la selección…
Eh… 0-0.
Ha marcado en la mitad de los goles que Colombia en la fase de clasificación.
Besos. Por eso.
Novena posición baja…
No, no baja un puesto. Se queda igual.
Se queda igual. Que en el pasado
power ranking del mes de septiembre…
Marruecos. Victoria por 1-0
ante Bahrein. El partido amistoso.
1-0 ante la República del Congo. Claro.
Partidos que te cambian. Te digo una cosa.
El concepto que hay de Marruecos. Marruecos es…
Arrasado en su grupo de clasificación.
Marruecos es la selección…
¿Qué?
… que por primera vez ha conseguido 16 victorias
consecutivas.
A nivel mundial. ¿Ah, sí?
A nivel mundial. Sí, sí. Ayer
consiguió el récord después de esa victoria…
Eh…
Y son 16. Ante la República del Congo.
Ante la República del Congo. No salía.
16 victorias a nivel consecutivo. Casi nada.
En la fase de clasificación que ha hecho, de verdad, es perfecta.
Son 8 victorias,
22 goles a favor, solo 2 en contra.
Con esto que estamos diciendo, si Marruecos
se mete en cuartos, no lo podremos, Tildalder.
No es sorpresa. Es que yo creo que ya no será sorpresa.
El año pasado… O sea, el año pasado. El Mundial 2022
hizo semifinales.
Y tuvo carácter sorprendente, evidentemente.
Sobre todo por el grupo de dónde venía, que es
Bélgica y Croacia era, ¿no? Sí.
Y que elimina a España, elimina
a Portugales.
A Portugal, sí. Sí, sí.
Portugal en cuartos, claro. Portugal en cuartos.
Y en semifinales. Se mide a Francia
y hay muchos jugadores que no han parado de crecer,
otros que están entrando en dinámica.
Y ahora tiene una muy buena
piedra de toque en enero, que es la Copa África.
He notado posición, misma posición
del ranking. Y…
haciendo deméritos para
bajar. Alemania, que ha ganado
los dos partidos, 4-0 ante Luxemburgo y 0-1
ante Irlanda al Norte, pero de verdad…
A mí me deja mucha turista. Luego llegará
al Mundial y será Alemania, igual que lo fue
en la Eurocopa, que para mí fue el reto más
complicado, Adri. Pero el
Kakao, con Kimic de lateral derecho.
O Kakao ya no juega, creo.
Una de las nacionalizaciones más famosas.
Con Nabri y Goreska
de interiores por delante, tenía balón.
Un extremo, aunque ahora está
jugando por dentro en el Bayern, y un Goreska que no tiene giro.
Birx abierto, va de izquierda.
Adeyemi abierto, anda derecha.
Super abiertos. Y en el caso de Birx,
además poco participativo para lo abierto que está
jugando. Sensación de que Nagueroz Mantovia
no sabe muy bien qué hacer con esta
selección, con lo que tiene entre manos.
Y se le está atascando un poquito el proceso, lo está sacando
adelante con resultados, lo cual está dando tiempo.
Pero las sensaciones… Echa mucho de menos a
Musiala de todas formas. Pero a nivel de sistema,
porque le hemos visto probar el sistema de tres,
el de cuatro, el de terminar
encajar las piezas y por el momento le está
salvando un poco también que Wolltemad
está inspirado en el inicio de campaña. Marco
ante Irlanda. Yo confío en Musiala.
Yo creo que Musiala
puede agilizar un poquito esto.
Lo que no veo es lo de tirar a Kimic
al lateral derecho. Yo tampoco. En séptima
posición, baja
un puesto respecto
al pasado power ranking.
El segundo partido es la selección
de Brasil. Goleada 5-0
Corea del Sur. Calló 2-3
ante Japón. Es verdad que con muchas
rotaciones en el segundo partido.
Tuviste el segundo encuentro,
Adri, el de Japón, un poquito caótico.
A mí me gustó mucho ante Corea.
Creía que le íbamos a poner más arriba.
Con bastante intercambio de posiciones el día de Corea,
bastante movimiento, bastante dinamismo, no tanto el día
de Japón y al final te acaban remontando.
Al final se te acaba escapando el partido.
Amistoso sí, pero te lo acaban remontando
con goles bastante mejorables.
Os recomiendo el partido de UEDA
ante los centrales de Brasil.
A mí, vamos, yo veo a la selección
española. ¿Quién jugaron ante Corea?
Eran Veraldo y Fabricio Bruno.
Lo de Veraldo. Lo de Veraldo
Buffer. Pero los titulares del otro día
fueron Gabriel y Militao. Está también
Marquinhos. Es que esos
tres centrales sí que te dan seguridad.
Pero es que lo del otro día fue… El Alisson.
Gabriel,
Militao, Marquinhos. Los dos que queráis.
Casemiro y…
Bruno Guimaraes. Bruno
Guimaraes. Bruno Guimaraes.
Ostras, me parece un
quinteto de seguridad
para luego ver todo el talento que puso por delante.
El equipo B de Brasil
es para verlo, ¿eh? La línea defensiva
que es la que ante Japón entera es
Carlos Augusto en lateral izquierdo,
Paulo Enrique en lateral derecho,
Fabricio Bruno y Veraldo.
Los centrales. A mí lo que me gusta
es Fabricio Bruno. Fabricio Bruno mola.
El otro día… Vaya línea de cobraste.
Una mola para… Mola para…
Tengo que decir, es que
da la sensación de que este Brasil tiene jugadores…
El suplente de Alves era Maicon. Tiene jugadores
muy al inglés y le pasa mucho a Bruno Guimaraes.
No es un jugador con magia
que hemos visto mucho tiempo en el centro del campo de Brasil,
sino que es más un 4x4
que no termina de definirse en ninguna de esas
facetas. Y una cosa muy breve.
Eso de no tener buenos recambios,
buen manquillo, a Brasil está
jugando muchas malas pasadas en los torneos cortos.
Los centrocampistas también.
La línea de centrocampistas de Brasil,
en lo que es Hilo 21, es más tópico de botacola.
Cero imaginativos. Pero si decía
Andrés Pereira que Uruguay tenía
jugadores que soñaban…
Que soñarían en sexta posición.
En sexta posición.
Subiendo un puesto por las noticias
individuales que están recopilando en los últimos meses
y colectivas, Países Bajos
ganó 0-4 a Malta, bueno,
4-0 a Finlandia. Pero
ese centro del campo con Rangers,
con Frenkie de Jong, con Grabenberg…
Todos en el mejor momento de su carrera.
El tema de los centrales, de País que sigue
marcando goles. Coigas porque sabemos
que el futbolista es selección.
Cuidado, eh. Llega un poco
de tapadita el torneo. Sí, sí. Creo que
eso está hablando quizás poco de la selección de
Países Bajos. Yo creo que es más sensación.
Está hablando más de Holanda. Sí, claro.
De Holland. De Holland. Yo te diría que
de las Europeas es
la que más claro, o sea,
quitando a España, poniendo a España fuera,
me parece que es la que más claro tiene lo que hace.
Totalmente de acuerdo. Creo que es
la más peligrosa por eso. Porque creo que Portugal
está en un momento un poco de duda.
Claro. Le hemos visto a mí. Mira,
lo introducimos. Baja un puesto respecto a ese tema.
Portugal en quinta posición, ganó 1-0 a Irlanda.
In extremis empató.
También se empataron
In extremis con el resego de Sober Sleij
ante Hungría. Pero hay
mucho debate en Portugal. Es lo que tú dices.
Y mira que a mí Portugal
me parece una gran selección.
Pero ahí, como… No es el mismo ambiente
que en España o en Países Bajos como tú haces.
Es como que el haber ganado no les ha permitido
seguir creciendo
o utilizarlo como algo positivo.
Les está viniendo como mal.
Como si hubiera sido, oye, hemos ganado a la selección
española y ahora no sabemos a qué
aspirar. ¿Somos favoritas para el mundial? No, no.
Yo, sinceramente, veo a la
selección portuguesa en una situación preocupante.
A mí me sorprende la crítica que hacía Roberto Martínez
en Portugal. A mí también. Tengo la sensación de que no
se lo han terminado de creer. Pero…
¿Has jugado bien?
Pratamente nunca.
Es una selección que no… O sea, es un entrenador
Roberto Martínez que cuesta
¿cómo decirlo? Ir con él.
Porque creo que hace tan defensivo
a sus equipos que llega un momento que
dices, oye, macho… Creo, mira,
lo que analizábamos ahora de que nos estamos divirtiendo
con España, de que los partidos pueden ser
una filfa pero que nos lo pasamos
bien, esto no pasa en Portugal. No pasa.
No, no. Tampoco pasaba antes.
Entonces, claro, cuando tu único parapeto son los resultados
y no ganas, pues es normal que haya críticas.
Ya, ya, ya. Pero mi sensación
es que es una selección
un poco lo de
Alemania. Que cuando llegue
la competición yo no les quiero ver ni
en pintura. No, pero esto…
Escuchaba ayer la rueda de prensa que ha ido
Jesús Martínez, el dueño
de Grupo Pachuca. Me encanta.
Lo adoro. Son más que de súbitas.
O sea, es que debería ser el dueño de todos
los clubes de fútbol español. O sea, es que
es el mejor. Todos entrarían en Europa. Es el mejor.
Y decía aquello
o analizando todos los técnicos
que ha tenido el Grupo Pachuca
desde que llegó el Real Oviedo.
Decía, bueno, Álvaro Cervera.
Es que yo veía los partidos y me daban ganas de llorar.
Sí, hablaba de que con Carreón le gustaba lo que…
Claro, pues pasa algo parecido con Portugal.
En cuarta
posición baja un puesto
respecto al pasado power ranking Francia
que ganó 3-0 a Azerbaiyán. Empató
ante Islandia a dos. No estaba en
vape, de acuerdo, pero es lo que comentábamos también
con España, que faltaban seis titulares.
Si hubiera ganado el partido
ante Islandia se hubiera metido. O sea, ya sería
selección mundialista. Todavía no.
Para mí eso tiene también un poquito de… Sí.
Una Francia que lo estuve viendo
en el anterior parón y empieza a encontrar
ya la forma, creo,
bastante reconocible para jugar. Ya en vape
también es nueve puro de la selección. Ya no parte
desde un costado. Olise por detrás
como media punta, que creo que lo complementa bastante
bien. Dembele va a ir a derecha. Mateta
entrando ya en los planes
de Schaaf sin la punta. El doble pivot
de Chouameni Manoukone, que también
está bastante asentado. Aunque yo creo
que va a jugar Rabiot.
Rabiot Manoukone.
No. Rabiot Chouameni, yo creo.
Sí, yo creo que Manoukone ahora no le quita.
Yo creo que no. Es la mejor noticia
de los dos parones que llevamos. El otro día
por lo visto jugó vincamavincam. No vi el partido.
Es otro nombre ahí.
Pero bueno. Baja un puesto
Francia. Baja un puesto Portugal. Ya lo hemos
dicho. ¿Quién sube dos?
Inglaterra. Tres cero agales
en partido amistoso. Eso sí. Cero cinco Aletonia
selección ya clasificada. La única selección
europea. De hecho, que está clasificada
para el mundial. Y
avances. ¿Ales en la gestión
de Thomas Tuchel? Sí, sobre todo estamos
viendo un muy buen Eliot Anderson que está jugando
muy bien. De clan rice ya asentado como
ese interior llegador.
Harry Kane obviamente este
sigue con su gran momento de forma. Y el
tema de Anthony Gordon, ¿no? Que debe ser ese futbolista
que genere desequilibrio partiendo desde la banda
izquierda. Marcó el primer gol. Sí, eso es.
Había su poco más sencilla cuando Harry Kane
juega en tu equipo. Es el delantero de
las elecciones. Infraredoradísimo, Harry Kane.
Pero delanterazo espectacular. Es una cosa
ahora mismo top tres mundial.
En estos momentos. En
segunda posición
en septiembre tuvimos a España.
¿Han?
Ahora
claro.
Ha habido que tomar. Son decisiones
que decía Miguel Ángel Russo.
En segunda posición
Argentina
victoria uno cero a Venezuela, cero seis a
Puerto Rico. No es tanto
porque haya hecho algo mal a Argentina, evidentemente.
Sino porque ya en septiembre
vosotros queréis colocar a España. Sí.
Yo abrazo
no solo la democracia sino también el juego
español. Así que en segunda posición
Argentina y en primera la selección
española ahora mismo para la pizarra de Quintana
máxima favorita
a ganar el mundial. Abrazas más el juego
español que la democracia. Sí.
Creo que el juego español te atrae.
Termina de convencer.
No tanto la democracia cuando
hayamos votado de manera interna. Recuerdo que
hice una broma al respecto en el post de la Zon,
unos primeros post de la Zon con Sorin.
Estabamos votando el once de la
jornada.
Mandó un abrazo a Juanpi, por cierto, un
cracazo. Y dije bueno,
porque la gente votaba un once y nosotros
dábamos otro. Y era una posición que
había votado por mucho maíz tocule
y ese jugador, aunque había estado mejor otro de un equipo
inferior, digo bueno, la democracia está sobre la dada.
Y dice Juanpi. No, no, no.
Fue muy bueno eso, fue muy bueno.
Porque claro, Sorin no
conocía nada, Miguel. Claro, claro.
Y dijo... Y Sorin estaba como, pero tengo aquí
un dictador. Y dijo, el peinado,
la pose autoritaria y este mensaje
no. La duda es
¿qué opinaría Juanpi Sorin
del power ranking?
Pues... Bueno, caga el suyo.
Claro, claro. Caga el suyo.
Y no comparte ellas nada. Los Soriners.
No pasa nada, pues. Bueno, ¿pero tú estás de acuerdo
con poner España en la primera?
Pero qué decir.
Que es que Argentina ha jugado a dos amistosos.
Bueno, pero... Y los ha ganado los dos.
Sincero, Puerto Rico. No como Colombia.
Pero... Claro.
Es que qué decir. ¿Quién es
tu máxima favorita para el mundial? Una. Una selección.
Una. Una. Juan.
España. Ya está.
Pero... Quiero decir.
Lo era también hace
un mes. A verlo, no.
Si hubieséis hablado en WhatsApp lo hubiésemos puesto.
Claro. No, no. A ver.
¿Qué decías? No, no.
Es que tiene... Para que pase la democracia
hay que votar. No, no.
No vale con meter un chorizo en la
nada. Eso es una mentira
que os han colado. No, no.
La democracia está sobrevalorada.
Si no vas a votar te puedes quejar
también. Que es una bacalada, hombre.
Que tú votas y no sirve para nada, hombre.
Bueno, que...
España. Que me hayan puesto ahora la pizarra.
Piensa que es el programa
de Federico, ¿eh? Bueno.
España máxima favorita por delante
de Argentina, de Inglaterra,
Francia y Portugal. En sexta posición
yo creo que ahí hay un escaloncito.
Está Países Bajos. Luego Brasil
en octava posición Alemania.
Marruecos en novena. Y
entra por primera vez. Ya veremos si por
última Colombia por delante.